morning okay please step into the open
and up holy [ __ ]
identify yourself law abiding citizens
have nothing to fear okay no swirlies no
chocolate pudding left in the chairs of
brilliant mind why are you going to do
now Richie
Jesus
okay calm down ya know what's a fight
see all I heard that I hate that shiny
my dog right I'm just sucking eating a
dog to stay lying on us and
it's how I got this way I miss all mine
let's say I'd say yeah I [ __ ] missed
something
so there's like one around here
the [ __ ] is it
okay huh
it says it's like here
I'm [ __ ] facing it
okay [ __ ] it where's the other ones
you gotta go stairs
sure [ __ ] I do that
please step into the open and identify
yourself law-abiding citizens
I gotta go up so how r it yeah stairs
okay okay
kind of [ __ ] some people up you know in
a cyan school oh yeah guys I pranay i
cain't a special a new and chill that's
[ __ ] gross okay that they're sucking
locked
can I walk sideways as well okay okay I
thank ya ah
that's like I think this solo I was hit
my limbs are [ __ ] up basics eating dog
made this whole time
[ __ ] is in there
okay okay good
Hank's at the testing area gotta get in
there can I reach it No okay let's exit
ok bet he messed with the wrong dog
trainer to that I was singing out of dog
training Jesus how I talks I gotta hate
today
ok I just check up Wes Welker ok exit
oh [ __ ] I gotta finish this real quick
am i still getting out I can't tell I
think there's a terminal here hey the
[ __ ] I park it ok I need a [ __ ]
step back badly
if I can stimpacks here come on tough
[ __ ] a whetstone well I lives are
[ __ ] crap up ok I think what's my
exit
ok that kind of guy
as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i did this holy [ __ ] heck
hey god are you [ __ ] kidding me that
game is
please I guess luck in this cabin I'm
fry them all okay I'm frying them all
okay that's how i did thank you know get
right here okay yes yes yes yes I can I
got that's your breath jackets oh great
i forgot its guests oh good [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up jane says what [ __ ] class
tower
jenny says I guess just one thing at a
time right need some [ __ ] war dog
right it's disgusting but like I gotta
do it
it wants me to go sigh and I like what
I'm signing it down
that's me to go that can i'll let the
[ __ ] christ [ __ ] k Jesus
all right [ __ ] white I can't color
right now I gotta exit let's try to exit
ok ok I'm a chance ok
I do a [ __ ] say right here
again is it done okay there we go nice
no I don't that chat
I just [ __ ] like glowing nice [ __ ] there
no no no now there we go night dad
I